Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say'!
Do you know what to say when you talk about your personal interests?
Listen out for useful language for talking about personal interests.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Hi, Paul.
I made you a cup of tea.
Just how you like it, milk and two sugars.
Oh, thanks, Emir.
You're welcome.
So what do you do when you're not working?
Oh, umm,
not much.
I'm always really tired in the evenings and at weekends.
Haven't you got any hobbies?
Well, I've recently started doing meditation.
I didn't know you did meditation. I do too!
Oh, right.
So, um,
how often do you practise?
Most mornings usually, but if it's really busy, then sometimes it's hard to find time.
Yeah, I know what you mean.
I normally meditate once or twice a week.
I never have enough time to do it more than that.
What are you doing now?
Nothing much, just drinking my tea …
Hello again!
Now that's something you don't see in the office every day!
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for talking about your personal interests?
Listen to me and then repeat.
What do you do when you're not working?
I didn't know you did meditation.
I do too!
How often do you practise?
Most mornings, usually.
Sometimes it's hard to find time.
I normally meditate once or twice a week.
I never have enough time.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you talk about your personal interests in English.
Bye for now!